hi in this video I'm going to talk about
fatty acid metabolism both anabolism as
well as catabolism so let's talk about
fatty acid animalism first and then
fatty acid catabolism fatty acid
anabolism means fatty acid synthesis
what are the raw materials for fatty
acid synthesis the raw materials for
fatty acid biosynthesis are acetyl co a
and Malone Alcoa so where does this
acetyl co a come from the acetyl co a is
present inside the mitochondria and with
the help of citrate synthase enzyme it's
converted into citrate cause Estill Co a
cannot directly get outside into the
cytoplasm and all the reaction of this
fatty acid synthesis takes place in the
cytoplasm so acetyl co a have to get out
into the cytoplasm in order to perform
the other reactions so as a telco
efforts get converted into citrate with
the enzyme citrate synthase and gets
outside of the mitochondria into the
cytoplasm and in the cytoplasm citrate
is again converted into acetyl co a with
the help of enzyme citrate lyase now
this acetyl co wave would perform two
things one it would take part in the
condensation reaction for fatty acid
biosynthesis and from this acetyl co
wave Malinois wave would be formed and
one very important enzyme is as it I
will Co a carboxyl is as it is a
carboxyl is enzyme it would add a
carbonyl group as you can see as it'll
leak away and Malinois wave Maren Alcoa
has one carbonyl group extra and this
carbon carrier is biotin so for any
carboxylase enzyme biotin acts as a co2
carrier now second thing is where does
the reaction of these fatty acid
anabolism takes place what is what are
the enzymes it appears that the enzymes
are not isolated enzymes there is a huge
complex called fatty acid synthesis
is complex this fatty acid synthase
complex is comprised of seven domains
seven active sites and in e coli
multiple polypeptide are responsible for
these big complex but in human one
polypeptide is present and it has seven
domains and the enzymes presenting this
domain we will find them step by step
but back to the first step the first
step is condensation condensation
between what acetyl co 8 and Malinois
wave so acetyl co a and malinovka way
would be condensed and the entire
reaction of these fatty acid animalism
would take place on the phosphor painted
hanging arm of ACP so the phosphoprotein
arm looks like something this this is
the chemical structure of the
phosphoprotein arm and the vitamin
pantothenic acid takes part to form this
chain now in this huge complex the fatty
acid synthase complex we have our
malinovka way and we have our acetyl coa
and they would condense and after
condensation this condensation reaction
would be triggered by beta key to assign
acp synthase after condensation it would
produce something called beta key to
assign a CP so this thing is called beta
key to assign acp why it is called beta
because if we comb this this is a zero
at carbon so this would be alpha carbon
and this will be beta carbon so in the
beta carbon we have something keto group
that is why it is called beta key to
assign acp then it would undergo a
reduction reaction so the basic scheme
of the next reaction would be reduction
dehydration and for the reaction
reduction so inside the cell the
reduction would take place with the help
of energy
eh and where does this NADPH come from
this NADPH come from pentose phosphate
pathway as you remember
so from pentose phosphate pathway NADPH
is generated and this NADPH is used in
this reduction reaction and NADPH would
be converted into an ATP and it would
reduce this V Turkey to si a CP into
beta hydroxy si ACP so you can see in
the place of keto group now we have a
hydroxyl group in the beta position here
is alpha 0 alpha and beta and we have a
hydroxyl group in this position so it is
reduced to beta hydroxy assign a CP and
the enzyme would be a reductase enzyme
so the enzyme name is Peter keto si a CP
reductase or KR so as you remember KR is
a integral part of these huge fatty acid
synthase complex now back to the
reactions the next reaction would be our
dehydration reaction the hydration
reaction means water would be explained
out of the system so from here water
will be experi and a double bond would
be formed so it would be in knowing a CP
it would be in oil a CP or unsaturated
CP then what will happen for the
reduction reaction would take place and
again the reaction reduction reaction
would helped by NADPH which comes from
the pentose phosphate pathway and it
will reduce this double bond into our
total butyl group so this total thing is
our butyl group and it is called the
buter ISEP
so the whole cycle would be repeated
over multiple times so after a first
cycle the total number of carbon is here
4 and after two cycles again
condensation would take place and the
total number of carbon would be 6
and then eight and up to 16 carbon this
cycle could be repeated to form 16
carbon per metric acid so this is how
the fatty acid anabolism takes place
into the cytoplasm of the cell now let's
talk about fatty acid catabolism and
fatty acid catabolism would take place
in the mitochondria so in order to these
breakdown of fatty acid we need the
fatty acid inside the mitochondria but
the fatty acid cannot get inside the
mitochondria directly so fatty acid
first have to be charged so fatty acid
with the help of quail I guess as a
takeaway like is as I will go in like is
fatty acid would be converted into fatty
acyl Kawai and with the help of
carnitine acyltransferase it there are
two connecting acyl transferase in the
mitochondria carnitine acyltransferase
one and conical acyl transferase two
with the help of carnitine
acyltransferase what will happen fatty
acid would get inside into the
mitochondria inside the mitochondria the
reactions that would take place is just
the opposite
as now fatty acid synthase synthesis the
first reaction is vety a selca way would
be converted into alpha beta in oil co a
and this reaction would be catalyzed by
SI lq8 the hydrogenous it could be taken
as at the hydrogenation reaction
ultimately the thing is it is oxidation
the whole thing is oxidation so hydrogen
is removed from this part and here we
would have hydrogen if we see these two
parts
we would see the number of hydrogen is
reduced so that means there is an
oxidation so this first part is
oxidation but remember our first part of
the fatty acid synthesis bar pathway was
action but here we have oxidation then
what we have we would have a hydration
reaction hydration means addition of
water just in contrast we there we have
in the fatty acid fatty acid synthesis
pathway we have dehydration that means
removal of water but here we have
addition of water here we have addition
of water so in the beta position we have
addition of the hydroxyl group and this
is called beta hydroxy fatty acid Kawai
and the enzyme that performs this
reaction is in oil co a hydratase and
after these hydration reaction another
series of oxidation reaction would take
place and these oxidation reaction is
catalyzed by beta hydroxy si co-ed
dehydrogenase again our dehydrogenase
enzyme so this oxidation reaction would
ultimately produce a keto group at beta
position so this is also called beta
Tito si wave after P Tokita si way what
would happen ty relays enzyme would take
part in the reaction and thigh relays
would break down these fatty acyl Kawai
and produce a molecule of acetyl co and
from this fatty acyl quai from this
fatty acyl kwai further cycle of beta
oxidation would take place again a
molecule of acetyl co a would be
produced from these breaking down these
compound and up and the breakdown of
these whole fatty acyl CoA would take
place so this was a overview overview on
both the fatty acid anabolism and fatty
acid catabolism reaction but the main
thing we have to see that in the fatty
acid anabolism and catabolism both takes
place inside the cell but one take place
I mean the fatty acid
reactions take place in the cytoplasm in
the cytoplasm whereas the fatty acid
catabolism reaction takes place in the
mitochondria now
the basic reaction scheme for the fatty
acid anabolism and catabolism are quite
different just opposite to each other
you can see so first step would be
reduction then we have dehydration and
then we have reduction but here what we
have we have oxidation then hydration
and then again oxidation so in this way
these two pathways are related hope you
have enjoyed please like and subscribe
thank you